foreign
[Music]
p1983
1500
and we go for our
patented Sicilian
we still have not gotten a single open
system everybody is still playing the
Battle of Bishop C4 I truly hope we'll
get something a little bit different
just for some variety
even in alapan Smith more anything
except the battle lyrics we've been
getting Non-Stop
thus far wow our opponent already okay
F4 nice
so F4 is a move that we have faced I
want to say something like three or four
times throughout all of our speed runs
and every time we have responded in
exactly the same way I have explained
this move at length so I won't go
through the motions again we'll make the
move and then I'll recap it after it's
already made
the move is 2d5 and this is the reason
why the Grand Prix attack starts with
Knight C3 the whole purpose of going
Knight C3 first is actually to prevent
D5
and the way that we punish F4 is by
showing white that he should have gone
Knight C3 first F4 is not a mistake it's
a totally legitimate variation but it's
considered a little bit dubious it's
considered inaccurate
so
if white takes on D5
we are not forced to play a scandi with
Queen takes D5 that goes against the
whole point of the move D5 does anybody
remember what the move is against Ed
yeah very nice we play Knight F6 and we
actually have it on the board
and white Primos Knight C3 he I think
obviously thought we were going to play
Queen takes D5 if you're looking at this
for the first time you should be puzzled
and you should be wondering why white
can't just play C4 and secure the extra
Pawn well the reason as I'll recap after
the game is that black has E6 and after
the trade we get tremendous positional
compensation for the sacrifice Pawn as
in black is flat out better there so at
this point we can safely recapture the
pawn on D5
and of course the whole point is that in
the event of the trade the queen on D5
is a million times safer than it is with
the Knight still on B1 because white
does not have a second Knight to put on
C3 and if white plays Queen takes D5 and
then the move C4 then all that white
does is create more massive weaknesses
massive holes in the center
okay Bishop C4
interesting play
so of course I see that there is a
hanging Pawn on F4
you should remember though that the
spirit of this line is not necessarily
to grab a bunch of Pawns and fall behind
and develop and that's not really what
we want to do
so the kind of Russian Schoolboy inside
of me says that the most prudent the
most practical option here without
spending too much time is just to drop
the Knight back to B6
especially because after Knight B6
Bishop to B3 we have a sick move we have
C4 and that virtually traps the bishop
and forces white into a super awkward
check on A4 and we definitely want to
eliminate the light squared Bishop
because the dark Squad Bishop is a
terrible piece why is it a terrible
piece because of the Pawn on F4 because
the pawn completely hems in the bishop
and also I don't like Knight takes F4
because of the response Queen F3
and things kind of become unpleasant
there if you turn on the engine yeah
probably black is somehow better maybe
Knight F4 Queen F3 Knight back to E6 but
that's an awkward move too because it
blocks the bishop in so again notice
that I'm largely using my intuition I'm
not even really calculating Knight takes
so far I'm not interested in that
because it's not worth it it's not worth
contorting yourself like that over a
pawn that we actually want to remain on
the board this Pawn is in our favor
because it's completely drying up
White's King side play it's blocking in
the bishop and it sticks out like a sore
thumb let's go Knight B6
and when I say practical this is kind of
what I mean we didn't spend too much
time we spent a second evaluating and we
just decided let's play Let's play it
safe
forcing the bishop to make a decision of
course Bishop B5 check we probably will
play Bishop to D7 encouraging the trade
of light squared Bishops although Bishop
B5 we could very safely play Knight C6
as well of course we are not really
fearing uh Bishop takes C6 check but I
think we'll go Bishop D7
the bishop doesn't have too many good
squares Bishop b3c4
I mean if Bishop B2
then we simply continue our development
with Knight C6
and generally what I want you to see
here is that we have
lovely control of this D4 Square that's
the function that the C5 Pawn serves oh
my God Bishop F7 I was gonna point this
move out it's not entirely stupid
obviously but it's just as obviously
unsound and there's no question that the
sacrifice is on sound but I know that a
lot of people they struggle to refute
these types of sacrifices and it can be
scary to face a move like this so let's
delve head first into the complications
Knight to F3
so
there's essentially a short-term plan
here and then a long-term plan the
long-term plan is to carry out a
maneuver that is commonly referred to as
castling by hand or manual castling
manual castling is just what you know
the name refers to you can't castle in
the conventional way because you've
already moved your king so you build the
castling formation from scratch you get
the bishop out of the way you shift The
Rook to f8 or E8 and then you tuck the
king back to G8
but of course there is also a short-term
strategy that has to be adopted the
Knight on F3 threatens to jump into E5
does it threaten to jump into G5 not as
much because Knight G5 Chuck we can tuck
our King back to G8 in fact we can do
the same thing after 95 but obviously we
should avoid Bishop G4 like the plague
that simply blunders the bishop
so I don't think that we really need to
do anything special here I think we just
need to develop our pieces ASAP and make
sure that we're not blundering any weird
uh weird mates
so
I think the simplest move actually might
even be just King G8 flat out straight
away not ideal because we're blocking in
a rook but we're also up a piece so
we're going to have to make some
concessions here I don't think it's
possible for black to carry out the
entire castling by hand maneuver because
it takes too long and the knight's gonna
jump into E5
so there's a couple of moves here
there's G6 which I quite like G6 is a
great move
because it you know threatens to feed
Kettle the bishop and get our King side
out in fact I love the move G6
because what's most important here is to
get our King side out that allows our
King to feel relatively safe the Knight
on B8 we will be able to develop later
right there's no rush to play the move
Knight C6 I think the classy move here
is actually G6
get your king side out so that the king
can feel a lot safer Bishop G7
and yes Knight G5 check we might even
bring the king back into the frying pan
with King to E8
but White's running out of minor pieces
what are White's attackers here one
attacker that's it the bishop on C1 is
never going to be able to play an active
role tonight on C3 doesn't really have
any prospects if white does not give a
check on G5 or E5 then obviously our
next move is going to be rook f8 and
then we actually do manage to Castle by
hand so we're trying white has to give a
check here to keep an inkling of Hope
alive
we got a raid from Jeffrey what's up
raid from gmjx welcome everybody as we
do a second Speed Run game you come at a
good time we are playing somebody who is
throwing
all of his pieces at us so we're
practicing how to refute on sound
attacks very very hard task I have to
give some kudos to our opponent this is
very very creative attacking chess this
is not easy to refute
so
what do we do here we we're facing the
move F5 it looks very scary
the point of the move F5 is obviously to
open up the file so Bishop takes F5
would play right into White's hands
Bishop takes up five would run into G4
and then if we keep gobbling White's
gonna have a double check with Knight E5
and that's precisely what the worst case
scenario looks like so if we are to take
on F5 we should clearly take with a pawn
but as I've said before any time upon
captures another Pawn or a piece you
need to figure out what squares are
newly accessible to yourself and your
opponent in this case to your opponent
so after the pawn shifts from G6 to F5
the effect of that move
is that the H5 square is now accessible
to White's Queen so what can white try
after G takes F5 well White's gonna give
a check on G5
and if we drop working carelessly back
to E8 then Queen H5 check
suddenly becomes very nasty followed by
a night Fork on F7 that's exactly how we
let the attack spin out of control
so after G F5 Knight G5 check we should
go the other way King G8 but still Queen
H5 may appear rather unpleasant there is
a main thread on F7 now can we defend
against that made threat we actually can
we can shift Our Queen over to f8 in
that situation
and it appears to me that White's attack
starts to fizzle out and then on the
next move we could play H6 and force the
Knight out of G5 but there is also a
third option here uh sorry a second
option because Bishop takes F5 or not
counting and that is just ask yourself
what if we ignore what if we just go
Rook at fate and continue castling by
hand as if nothing's the matter
well that seems like Madness because
after F takes G6 check H takes G6 aren't
we giving our opponent a discovered
check we are but the point is that
there's no way to win anything other
than a pawn the way that white can win a
pawn is by giving a check on E5 and
capturing on G6 but in that case our
King is safer than it's been the entire
game
so I actually think that these options
are alternatives G takes F5 is what I
would call a more principled option
where we're basically saying I don't buy
anything you're doing I believe in the
ability of my pieces to ward off the
immediate attacking threats
and that's actually what I want to do I
want to prove to you that you can go for
these types of moves and there's no
reason to fear ghosts in this situation
if you don't see a forced mate if you
don't see a way to actually cause
problems you don't need to be afraid
just because your king may seem
uncomfortable for a couple of moves okay
G4 just loses on the spot our opponent
is playing for tricks we're obviously
not taking on G4 what are we doing now
well we're following through on our
initial plan which is to do what
we have time all the time that we need
to play Rook to f8 castling by hand
we've completed it and we're gonna win
the game
very shortly thereafter
so yeah our opponent definitely finding
some creative ideas but that sack was
was just just way way way too early
and you just can't you can't win chess
games like that you got to develop some
of your pieces again can we play Bishop
takes F5 probably we could get away with
it I'm not even thinking about touching
that pawn get your king back to safety
keep your priorities straight and on the
next move we will casually take the pawn
on F5
if white goes Knight H4 notice that it's
White's king that's now uh Under Fire
because White's pushed all of his
kingside pawns forward arcing is now
safer than it's ever been Knight G5 is
not scary at all what should we do now
well white is not exactly stopping us
from recapturing the Pawn on F5
then I can guarantee you that we are
going to be the one hunting down whites
King soon enough
some of you are proposing Queen D4 check
I don't see the point of that move why
why would you want to send whites King
over to a safer Square the King on G1 is
a vulnerability you want to keep things
like this in your pocket
right you don't just want to sell all of
your Apple stocks you know 15 years ago
Queen D4 is a very valuable asset that
you really only want to pounce on when
it achieves something specific so it's
kind of one move itis right it's it's a
one move check that doesn't really lead
anywhere it doesn't ruin anything either
but
I think it's important to keep moves
like this in your pocket in reserve
because you can always play them White's
not preventing Queen D4 anytime soon
Queen H5
now Queen D4 looks a heck of a lot
better than it did on the previous move
why well what do I see well what I see
is that after Queen H5 The Rook on F1 is
what we call a type 2 undefended piece I
remind you type one a piece that's not
defended by any other pieces or pawns a
type 2 undefended piece a piece that is
only protected by exactly one other
piece other than a pawn
and the king is the worst Defender
because it's the easiest piece to force
off of a square by rule you must respond
to a check
so hopefully the puzzle pieces are
falling into place if we can force the
king away we might have a discovered
attack against white stroke how do we do
that well we give a nice little juicy
check on D4
white is actually forced to go Queen G2
because if King H1 the Rooks are staring
at each other and Bishop E4 check
is game over very important after and I
take C4
it's crucial that Rook takes F1 is a
check otherwise we would have allowed
the second capture on H7 with a win
now the game is still not over we still
need to be very careful because our
Queen side is still undeveloped and
there's still a lot of landmines that we
could step on in this position
so
we need to tread very very carefully
here
so there's two priorities here
the first priority is most important
priority is to defend H7 what is white
actually threatening here this is not a
mate the threat is Queen takes H7 and
then notice 96 with a fork the second
priority is that our Rook is hanging so
the question is can we deal with both at
the same time we most certainly can't we
use the weakness of the white king to
address the second priority first what
do we do we have two ways to do this I
like Queen G1 check because this also
sets up mating ideas
so let's start with Queen G1 check
and the second priority can be dealt
with very straightforwardly
importantly Queen E8 is this a scary
check it most certainly is not because
we can drop our Rook back to f8 that's
actually very important we should play
H6
now the game is over
again
might look scary might look annoying
but there's nothing just look at fate
District f8
perhaps this was unnecessary I will
admit that I kind of I saw H6 out of the
corner of my eye
and there's actually a ridiculous idea
here for white which is to go Knight
back to F3 that's what white should have
done
and after the game I'll ask you what the
proper response is to that move
okay
well what do we do now we just take the
Knight I don't see a single
compelling reason not to
perhaps we could have hunted for
checkmate with Queen F1 Rook F3 is not
made the Knight defends that square
don't forget that
sorry
G5
yeah our opponent definitely did kind of
play like a maniac that game but it's I
think very valuable to know how to beat
players like that because because they
can win a lot of games through
intimidation at this point the tables
have turned so again the Russian
Schoolboy kind of move is just to play
Knight to C6 and say I don't care about
the check on E6 because I can just drop
my king over to h8 but at this point the
white king
is wide open and we should start looking
for mate
and we can find made by process of
elimination there's really only one
check here that makes any sense what is
that check
again Rook F3 one is The Rook
Queen F1 to start can be played
intuitively this move is not gonna hurt
you can make this move with zero
calculation because it's not only is it
not going to hurt it also allows you to
bring your queen back to safety if you
want to cover the check on E6
but now it's time for calculation
because
one way that you can mess these types of
positions up and I think you can relate
to this sometimes when you force the the
opposing King to go further and further
into your territory you have to be aware
of a situation or you've sent the king
in so far that it actually becomes an
attacker and if you don't have any
checks in that situation you could get
yourself mated
so a situation like that arises after
Rook F4 check
King goes to H5
now there's exactly one check in that
position Queen to D1 check and suddenly
the king lands on G6 so if you want to
go for that position you have to
calculate one step further do we
actually have a way of getting to the
King on G6 and the answer is yes but you
have to see that move what's that hidden
move
Rook back to F6 excellent Rook back to
F6 forcing white to give up the queen
for the rook and that ends the game but
you have to see all of that before you
play Rook F4 or you could get yourself
mated especially because we're playing
without our Queen side
and that's why if you're not sure in a
situation like this just go Queen back
to F6 just simplify okay don't try to be
a hero unless you've calculated
everything out very concretely and in
this case I have so for most players I
would actually suggest just going back
to F6 or going back to F5 because this
is
you know we're cutting it a little bit
close here if not for Rook F6 I guess we
also have Queen takes C2 check but
that's it otherwise we get checkmated
otherwise we get checked but we can
pre-move okay I don't have free moves
enabled but that's it we win
okay
nice little miniature game
and as often happens it's White's King
that ends up getting mated uh even
though our opponent had the opposite
outcome in mind
so a pretty straightforward game
um previously we have faced the move C4
which I mentioned before the game and
you can browse through my old speedrun
videos to find a detailed explanation of
why this position is better for black
the tldr is that you've got a massive
outpost on D4 a terrible pair of Bishops
both of which are staring at you know
the C and the F pawns respectively and
tremendous development for black so this
is not a good line I think most people
who actually play
F4 as as their main line what they tend
to do is go Bishop to B5 check I think
this might be the only way for white to
fight for equality and the point is to
force black to put a piece on D7 you
might ask yourself where have I seen a
concept like that before well one of our
first Speed Run games in this new speed
run was in uh the Portuguese variation
D5 and Knight F6 this is like the poor
man's candy
and does anybody remember what my
suggestion was against this line from
White's perspective what line did I
recommend
yeah it was a check on B5 Bishop D7 and
back to E2 forcing one of Black's pieces
onto an awkward square that cuts contact
with the other pieces and after Knight
takes D5 you just get a small edge with
D4 so it's the same general type of
concept where you know you force the
piece onto D7 but in this case the
Knight on D7 is actually quite a nice
piece
because later on in the game it can jump
out to B6 and put more pressure on D5 so
if white tries Knight C3
you have a bunch of options here but the
most straightforward one is first to say
get off me get out of B5
obviously this loses the bishop so black
white either has to take on D7 and then
we can take back with the queen and if
white plays Queen F3 stubbornly clinging
to the pawn we push the pawn out to B5
fiancado the bishop and we've got a
dream dream set up with Knight takes D5
if D6 we still go Bishop B7
so that's no good and if white goes back
to E2 then we can go Knight B6 and we
can win back the pawn with a very
comfortable position
but if I remember correctly the sort of
stockfish recommendation here is is to
say listen I'm not in a rush to win the
D5 Pawn a lot of people they struggle
with these types of Concepts where you
feel anxious because you're down a pawn
but there's no way for white to keep
this Pawn alive in the long run so what
you can say is listen I'm gonna for
rather than artificially forcing the
bishop away from B5 and spending Tempe
I'm gonna let the bishop stay on B5 I'm
gonna go from the other end I'm just
gonna prepare castling so the best move
I think is just G6
both sides develop Knight F3 Bishop G7
castles castles and you've saved a bunch
of Tempe now you can go Knight B6
without having to worry about the whole
A6 operation and the bishop on B5 is a
very awkward piece it's just sort of
biting Into Thin Air after Knight B6
and if white tries to open up the center
well that's not helpful at all CD Knight
D4 and still you go Knight B6 and win
the pawn back and again the pawn on F4
is sticking out like a sore thumb it's
creating permanent weaknesses on the
king's side and the bishop on C1 is just
very unhappy
so I don't know of a single way to
justify this line for white if white
goes E5 then uh you go Knight C6 and
we've had a game here as well this is
just a great great position for black uh
but this is something that we'll talk
about later it's a fundamentally
different line
let's take a look at the game Ed at F6
Knight C3 Knight takes D5 okay Bishop C4
is reasonable and Knight back to B6
and of course white should play Bishop
B5 Check and Go for this position takes
I don't know what we would have taken
with I like taking with queen with the
queen in in these types of positions
because you you allow your knight to
come out to a more natural Square
but it's the same logic by the way uh
it's the same logic in the Moscow
variation that's why the most popular
move here is actually Queen takes D7 not
because the queen is so remarkable but
because you allow your knight to come
out to a more natural Square
same
Spiel stick here
if sorry if this should be five check
Bishop D7 takes takes and you are in
time to come out to C6 taking the sting
out of Knight E5
castles and why is it so important for
the Knight to be on C6 well remember
what I said earlier one of the main
positional underpinnings of this
position is our control over the D4
Square which prevents Dwight from
freeing himself with D4 white has to
satisfy himself with D3 and now we've
got just the positional the best word
for it is a clamp or clamping down on
the D4 Square we're making it hard for
white to develop properly
okay so black I would say is slightly
better here you could even play Bishop
to D6 because D4 never works takes takes
Bishop C5 pins the King again
white pays the price for putting the
pawn on F4
but Bishop takes F7 is just a complete
Bluff move
and I'm kind of happy with the decision
that we made here I think G6 is a move
that demonstrates that we know what our
priorities are right our priority is to
get the king side out of course I think
White's only chance to make this
quote-unquote work would have been to
give the check on E5 at least Force the
king back either to E8 or to G8 we
probably would have gone back to E8
and white is completely lost there's
just no attack we go Bishop G7 yes the
king is in the center but who cares the
center is actually a pretty safe place
to be here white is no pieces to attack
with there's nothing to talk about here
right there's just nothing to fear in
this situation
just because the king looks exposed is
only half the equation the opponent has
to have the actual Firepower to exploit
it
yeah just not much to discuss Bishop F7
is completely unsound but of course our
opponent hastened his defeat with first
of all to move out five
and second of all maybe the last chance
was Knight G5 check but the funny thing
is the engine even proposes King G6
perfectly safe Square followed by H6
this just shows you how bad this attack
laughing in White's face
completely laughing in White's face
um
actually this reminds me of something
this idea of walking forward with the
king is something people kind of rarely
think about and yet it's you know
it's sometimes possible to do that
sometimes putting yourself right in the
eye of the hurricane is actually the
best way to ensure the safety of your
king
um
I remember a game
let me look for it
there's a game that I saw in a dwaretsky
book
that
was a very kind of very instructive
illustration of using the king as an
active Defender
let me see if I
can figure out this game I don't know if
it's available in the database and if it
isn't actually I think it's in my book
I think it's in my positional chess book
let me see if I can track this down
let me see if I can track this down I
exercising
exercises
what's there
yeah let me set up the position on chess
base
so this is the game uh gaiach against
blogie
like seeing blue Gano pretty
controversial figure but the game is
still instructive and Lugia of course is
a very strong GM there's no denying that
uh he's he was an incredibly strong
player at his peak in the late 80s and
90s
in this example is uh really
Unforgettable so I think it was worth
tracking it down
okay
so
take a look at this position
okay so this position with black to move
loogie is is black here
so
there's a beautiful tactical detail here
which you have to spot in order to
figure this out you should notice that
the bishop on E6 is what I would call
semi-hanging it is hanging but
if if white takes it then you can take
and then take the Knight on H6 but Queen
takes C6 is still a threat it's still a
threat because if you calculate all the
way into the line after Bishop takes H6
white plays Rook takes E7 and look at
how Black's position collapses that's
already a pawn and there goes another
Pawn black has a completely losing end
game so you might say okay not a problem
let me move the bishop back to D7 here
white has a beautiful tactical idea that
leads to a win let's see who can find it
first this is not easy and it comes out
of nowhere
who can find it you're going to fall out
of your chair when you find this
so Bishop F6 doesn't do anything
it's an empty sacrifice but it's the
right idea remember thinking in terms of
squares a lot of you are seeing the the
kind of value of this construction but
what's preventing Bishop takes F6 from
being good removing the defender Queen
takes C7
that's the right move you suck the queen
you just take back and there's nothing
black can do
note the value of the Luft Square on H2
that means the back rank checks are
futile
and that's it black is no defense
against the mate on F6 just none the
only way to Stave it off is back to E6
but white doesn't need the Rook rookie 6
Bishop F6 is still made beautiful
Construction
rookie six it's still made with the
minor pieces
of course here black technically should
go King G7 but you're down a piece in a
thousand Pawns
so that's the reason why you can't move
the Bishop from E6 the same goes for
Bishop D5 it doesn't change anything
this check looks scary but the king just
hides away on H2 it's insane
so the question then becomes well what
the heck do we do if we can't move the
bishop and we can't not move the bishop
do we have a defense and loogie finds a
honestly a brilliant defensive idea and
this defensive idea has to do with kind
of division of labor the bishop on f8 is
overloaded the bishop on f8 is
fulfilling a crucial defensive Duty it's
guarding the E7 pawn and that's all it
should be doing so there's exactly one
piece that's kind of getting you know
the luxury treatment when you can't
afford the luxury treatment
so you need to get that put that piece
to work
you need to put the king to work King G7
only move
and the idea is very prosaic you're just
defending against Queen takes C6 you're
ensuring that at the end of this line
the bishop remains on f8 to guard the E7
pawn and notice that Bishop F6 it
doesn't work here maybe some of you are
thinking oh this is a fork but the king
steps back and defends the bishop
so this game was played in 1985 by the
way so King G7 is a brilliant move but
this is this is only part one so guyich
he should have played Queen takes C6 and
basically gone for a draw but why would
you go for a drive you know you're
almost mating he goes Queen F4 very
logical move he steps away with a queen
he attacks F5 and it appears that the
attack rage is on and now another double
exclamed move who can find it
very nice King to G6 look at this move
this traps the Knight because it
protects F5 again you use the king for
defense
and white says okay now I'll come back
to the old idea and white says check
and queen E3 and now step step three
and this is gonna knock your socks off
the winning move
if you think the king is a giga Chad now
just wait until the next move King H5
being H5
and that's it the bishop is hanging if
Queen takes C6 then after the trade you
pick off the bishop and the king is
obviously safe the king is safe here
totally safe
because
G5 is covered by the f-pawn very
important
so white has no choice but just to move
the bishop back depressingly and finally
loogie drops his own Bishop back and
having done all of the work with his
King The King enjoys its rightful
retirement on G6 here here here and
white simply resigned because there's
nothing left to play for and you're down
a piece and if Queen C7 the queen drops
back to D5 keeping everything protected
so a great example of using the king as
an active Defender
right the king is capable of a lot more
Than People realize and there's one
since we're on the topic there's one
other example that I want to show you of
kind of using the king as an active
Defender not only can you use the king
as an active Defender the king is a
surprisingly fast piece it's a slippery
piece and you should remember that you
can actually vacate the field of the
field of battle
um you can vacate the Danger Zone by
using your king itself you don't always
just have to use other pieces and
surround the king in a defensive cocoon
and one of my favorite illustrations of
that is the following game
is the following game
just a moment
and this is also in in the chapter on
defense in my book
just a moment please
oh crap
thank you
this is a really memorable example I
think
there we go
this is a grand master game between
Miguel elieskas Spanish GM I actually
played him before and the very famous
off Anderson uh absolute Legend from
1997 you can see how how high rated uh
these these players were
so old Anderson has gotten himself into
a
rather serious pickle here white has
just lifted The Rook as you can see to
H3
and it appears that the game is over
because what is white threatening well
not Queen H7 but of course White's
threatening to take on F6 and and then
to take on H7 with me so
trivially it may seem that the only move
here is to play H6
but H6 loses on the spot to Bishop takes
H6
and that's it white crashes through GH
Queen H6 is mate and if you go Knight H7
then obviously there's Bishop takes G7
if you try Knight G8 then the bishop
moves back to G5
and uh Knight H6 F6 is just complete and
utter devastation
so what do we do do we resign no we do
not you cold-bloodedly moved the king
away since she ate
and oh yes guys makes a move that it's
very hard not to make and yet it's a
mistake he plays Bishop takes F6 but the
king continues to run and you've opened
up a little escape hatch through E7
and it's very important to hear very
important that black has control of the
e-file because if white could have put
the Rook on E1 you could have closed
that escape hatch off and Checkmate of
the King on h8 as it stands you just
keep running
and then you make another little escape
window for your king with Rook to D7 the
king runs all the way back toward the
center
and then again it runs forward to E7 the
smoke has cleared and suddenly it's
black who's threatening to Checkmate the
white king with Queen F2 forcingly ask
us to drop his Knight back now Anderson
opens up his bishop and transitions onto
the offensive
Queen G8 I don't care Queen E5 take my
Pawn
the king ends up all the way on C7 where
it's perfectly safe and he ends the game
with a direct attack against White's
King
rookie seven
and elyesque is just gives up the game
bang bang checkmate
that's actually how the game ends now I
went very quickly through the kind of
second half of this but ultimately you
see
the idea and one of the key takeaways is
that the king can be used as an active
agent it just doesn't always just need
to sit in the corner and and watch its
own demise you can use the king as an
attacker or as a counter attacker and
you can use the king like uh you know
like a running quarterback you can
actually run with the King you should
never forget that
okay back to the game hopefully those
examples were enjoyable
and all of that stemmed from a move that
I would never play in this case this is
just unnecessary but it forces the
Knight back and now we can go H6 and
King H7 but of course the simple King G8
is perfectly sufficient
but after Queen H5 it's important that
you have the move Queen to f8
and whatever white does we just go H6 on
the next move we force the Knight away
and then we drop our Queen up to F7
that's it no attack left at all and then
we complete our development so that
would have been perhaps the most
resilient after G4 Rook f8 there is
nothing left to analyze because apart
from our King being safe it's now
White's king that's completely wide open
but the last point I want to make after
Queen D4 check
if White had gone King G2 what's the
absolute simplest move here what move
would you propose if you wanted to play
practically
who can tell me
and and once you see a move like this
you should play it I would just go Queen
G4 honestly I would trade Queens because
you're up a piece in a pawn the Knight
is kind of stuck Queen G4 is very simple
if you don't want to do that you can
just go H6
H6 is also perfectly sufficient
so this was nominally more resilient if
Rook F2 then Queen F2 and Bishop G4
picks up another Rook so this is kind of
nice simplifying wisely and of course
here Bishop B4 is game over
H6
if white would have gone Knight back to
F3 the funny thing is that the queen is
almost trapped here but you can just
again using a technique I've talked
about so so much giving giving away a
little bit of material in order to make
the task easier we give away an exchange
and just look at this position you're up
a full piece The Rook is coming to f8
the bishop has tied down the game is
over the knight's coming to D4
you know it's going to result in either
a queen trade or a checkmate
so
that was nothing to be afraid of and
neither was Queenie a check because of
Brook Cafe but we had to do a little bit
of calculation big deal wasn't anything
particularly you know uh Off the Wall
complicated
and here we used accurate calculation to
ensure that after King G6 you can drop
the Rook back to F6 and force white to
give away a full Queen and our opponent
resigned
so
That's All She Wrote ladies and
gentlemen any questions on this game or
on the example games of using the king
and the defense I have many many more
illustrative examples of uh using the
king and defending but we'll limit
ourselves to these for now can we look
at Queen H5 instead of Knight F3
sure so if instead of Knight F3 on move
seven white would have given a check on
H5 yeah probably this was the best move
we would have just gotten G6 and yes yes
white gets a second Pawn for the piece
but on the flip side accelerates our
path to manual castling and here we are
once again in time
to play Rook Cafe and this is a paper
tiger because notice that all the
squares on this diagonal are nicely
protected by our Knight so
this is also completely losing and the
problems are compounded by the fact that
white can't even castle that easily here
again notice that all of the problems
stem just from this one thing that's why
moving the pawn from F2 to F4 is just
never something that you should do
unless you're absolutely confident in
why you're doing it
that's about it so two pretty
straightforward games today but still I
think that these Illustrated some very
important basic concepts and I hope you
enjoyed it's late I think it's time to
call it a night
uh as much as I want to keep going I
could do like five more games but I need
to get some sleep because tomorrow is a
super super long day for me
and I should definitely be responsible
but for now folks enjoy Gary's stream
thank you so much for hanging out the
support today was incredible just want
to remind you that I have a YouTube
channel every subscription counts I'm
not putting out any Mittens videos so we
gotta compensate with a team effort
thank you all
and I'll see you tomorrow have a good
start to Saturday
[Music]